many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism questions along
these lines about revenge retaliation
resistance to aggression come up quite
frequently from people who are studying
stoicism and want to think about how to
apply it within the matrix of the real
lives that they are living and it's a
great question the Stoics do in fact
have quite a lot to tell us about these
but we want to make some important
distinctions for those who demand a
simple straightforward answer before
hearing the distinctions or the
discussion about them that gives us a
much better answer I'll just say this
the Stoics that leaves the classic
Stoics said that revenge is always a bad
idea it's it's going to entangle us and
all sorts of problems
and if by retaliation you mean the same
thing as revenge well the same answer
goes for that if by retaliation you mean
something like resisting aggression
against oneself or others for whom one
is responsible then there could be some
legitimate point to it so let's make
some distinctions right off the bat when
we talk about revenge we're talking
about imposing something that we
recognize as bad or evil upon another
person because they did that either to
ourselves or to somebody else that we
care about they might be you know fairly
similar things like when you say well
I'm gonna cheat on you because you
cheated on me they may be very
dissimilar but the idea is that we're
gonna punish somebody somehow and that's
going to make us feel better
retaliation might mean the same thing as
revenge for for quite a few people and
then we could also talk about resistance
and retaliation might fit in
that so when we're called upon to resist
what other people are imposing wrongly
on us or those that we care about or
those that were responsible for or those
who can't defend themselves then that's
something a bit different than revenge
even though we might be doing the same
physical action like you know punching
somebody or you know putting troops out
onto the battlefield or beginning a
lawsuit or firing off an email or
something along those lines it's the
motivation that really matters so we can
think about you know what is going on
with revenge what is a person attempting
to get out of it and then we'll evaluate
that from a stoic perspective and then
we can think about resistance and
retaliation might figure in on either
side so let's talk first about revenge
what is going on from a stoic
perspective when a person is desiring
revenge when they're attempting to gain
revenge when they've actually avenged
themself on another person so to begin
with there is a desire there and it's
going to be one that's going to be
within the modality of anger and the
Stoics distinguished a couple different
types it might also be you know hatred
of some sort if it bleeds over into that
but it's going to be within that
spectrum and the desire here is to
impose something bad upon somebody else
to make them hurt to make them suffer to
take something away from them to
humiliate them to have other people look
on and say AHA they they got what they
deserve so there's also a sense of
justice to it and this can be very
deceptive
the Stoics would say so we're you know
what are we doing in this case we're
damaging another person and we think
that that's going to make things better
we're also damaging ourselves in the
process the Stoics would say Epictetus
actually talks about this saying
somebody has hurt you so you think
you're going to hurt them in return and
that's going to actually make things
better they did the wrong
you're gonna make things right by doing
wrong so the Stoics really you know it
would say that that's counterproductive
not only in terms of making things right
but also in terms of your own personal
development there's there's a lot of
ways in which seeking revenge can really
screw you up
you know it also involves being too
focused on what the Stoics would call
externals and valuing them much too
highly not viewing them as what the
stomach is called indifference which can
be you know useful and in some respect
but as if they possessed good in
themselves and what might these be like
your reputation somebody you know says
something that that makes you feel as if
your reputation has been damaged so
you're gonna damage their reputation in
response the Stoics would say this is
really a loss of perspective in many
respects some people think that the
Stoics are going to simply say never
resist anything whatever somebody does
let them do and there are some passages
that you can find in various stomach
texts that seem to go along those lines
but they'll almost always be within a
context where some resistance some
rational resistance some thoughtful you
know some well-founded resistance is in
fact not just legitimate but sometimes
required of us particularly if we see
somebody engaging in injustice against
other people especially non Stoics who
aren't going to be able to take it as
well who are in fact thinking that
they're being hurt by somebody saying
bad things about them or taking things
away from them or depriving them of
their freedom all these sorts of things
if we see that happening Stoics would
actually say well we should call it out
and we should as far as we can resist it
you're gonna find Stoics not only
talking about this in for example Seneca
or in you know Cicero in his on duties
he actually
as that if you don't prevent injustice
from taking place when you could prevent
it harm happened in other people
you yourself commit injustice as a
result we see marcus aurelius concerned
with this and the idea is we're not
supposed to go looking for for things to
resist there's already you know some
cases where we probably do need to put
our foot down and you know if it happens
to be the case that we're placed in a
position where we do have to exercise
power Authority and tell people this is
wrong I'm going to have to punish you
then we might in fact even allow
ourselves to appear as if we're angry
although we shouldn't be angry this is
again Cicero and Seneca both suggesting
this this sort of thing
but notice what's going to be going on
there it's not motivated in the same way
that revenge is so some retaliation some
responses to aggression could in fact
fall under this this rubric of rational
resistance but we have to be very very
careful that we're not misleading
ourselves and slipping into something
that's more like revenge if you found
this answer helpful for you then please
share it with others who might benefit
from it this work is entirely supported
by crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Sadler